Okay. Well, this first code snippet doesn't assign streams at all.
So none of these operations declare a stream, and therefore they're all in the default stream.
And since they are in the same stream, each one must complete
before the next one in that stream is allowed to run.
So cudaMemcpy will run for 1 second, kernel A will launch and run for 1 second,
and cudaMemcpy will run from another second, will copy the memory down,
do some operation on it, copy the memory back up.
And after 3 seconds the results will be ready for the host.
This next code snippet does declare a stream. It puts them all in s1.
And so since all 3 operations are in the same stream,
the previous operation must complete before the next one can start.
So once again, this will take a second, this will take a second,
this will take a second, and the final result will be ready in 3 seconds.
This one's a bit more complicated.
Here I'm doing 2 operations on different chunks of memory,
so I'm copying h array 1 into d array 1, calling kernel A on d array 1,
and copying d array 1 back to h array 1.
And then I'm copying h array 2 to d array 2, doing some operation on d array 2 by launching kernel B,
and copying d array 2 back to h array 2.
So the first 3 operations are in stream 1.
So cudaMemcpyAsync will be called,
and it'll start a memory copy to happen on the GPU
and then CPU execution will continue; the next statement will happen.
We don't stop and wait for Memcpy to finish before we execute the next statement,
which is the launch of kernel A.
Kernel launches are always asynchronous.
So, in effect, this queues up the launch of kernel A,
which will be run on the GPU after this Memcpy has finished,
and it proceeds to the next statement, which is another cudaMemcpyAsync,
to copy the results of kernel A back onto the host.
All 3 of these are in stream 1, so they will all wait for each other on the GPU,
but the host just issues a command, issues a command, issues a command.
It doesn't stop. It proceeds to cudaMemcpyAsync in s2.
And so now it starts another asynchronous memory transfer.
This one, because it's in s2, doesn't have to wait for any of these operations to complete,
so it gets started right away. It'll complete in 1 second.
It calls kernel B in 1 block of 192 threads, also in s2,
and then calls cudaMemcpyAsync, again in s2, to copy the results back.
So the first memory copy will happen, these next 2 operations in s1 will get queued up,
and the next memory copy will happen essentially immediately.
So in the first second this Memcpy and this Memcpy will be running,
in the next second kernel A will be running and kernel B will be running,
and in the final second the return Memcpy will be running in s1
and the return Memcpy will be running in s2.
And so the minimum amount of time this can take,
if all of the operations that can run concurrently do run concurrently, will again be 3 seconds.
But in this 3 seconds we'll have actually gotten twice as much work done.
We've overlapped the execution here.
And I phrased this very carefully when I talked about the minimum time this is going to take.
It's worth noting that there's a lot of reasons why it might not be able to overlap all of these operations.
Some older GPUs can't do this many asynchronous Memcpys at the same time.
And I was pretty careful to launch a single block, so this probably will not fill the GPU.
On the other hand, if kernel A had run tens of thousands of blocks,
it might well fill up the GPU with those blocks
before kernel B got a chance to start filling the GPU with any of its blocks.
And so kernel B might end up waiting on kernel A simply because resources are not available to run it.
The final example is the same operations just reorganized.
So in this case we issue both Memcpys in stream 1 and 2,
we launch both kernels in stream 1 and 2, and we issue both Memcpys back in stream 1 and 2.
So rearranging these things shouldn't make a difference.
The minimum time that this could take is still 3 seconds.